[Musique]
attention il ya un préavis de grève qui
a été déposés à la sncf par la cgt
l'unsa et sud-rail et ça concerne
notamment les trains régionaux sur l'axé
sud-est les cheminots réclament une
augmentation de salaire alors du 17 au
19 décembre au moins le trafic sera
certainement perturbé et syndicats
déplorent un manque de reconnaissance du
travail il réclame une prime qu'ovide
ainsi qu'une revalorisation des salaires
le président de la république sera donc
l'invité de tf1 demain une heure et demi
d'émissions enregistrées alors valérie
pécresse saisi le csa estime que le
président fait campagne et fait ouvrir
les chaînes de télé à sa demande nous
allons le faire nous allons saisir cette
instance qui si elle était effectivement
indépendante courageuse pourrait
peut-être recadrer le candidat président
emmanuel macron parce que c'est un
candidat président le 29 janvier 2012
nicolas sarkozy devant huit chaînes
mobilisés ce soir du jamais vu tf1
france 2 bfm itélé lci france 24 la
chaîne parlementaire son temps de parole
a été décomptée et il a été considéré
comme présumé candidat par le sait ça
appliquez donc les mêmes règles puisque
vous semblez les ignorer
valérie pécresse dit quoi elle dit
sincérité et lucidité esprit de
responsabilité quel contraste entre les
propositions d'aujourd'hui et celle de
jeudi dernier j'imagine que ce qui était
valable pour nicolas sarkozy les pour
emmanuel la belle chanson on est en
décembre on n'est pas encore en janvier
les règles du csa elles sont très
claires
elles sont très claires les règles du
csa
est clair qu'il faut qu'il clarifie sa
position au fond on voit bien que c'est
un candidat quoi bon donc ça devient un
peu insupportable qui l'utilisent
absolument tous les tous les moyens pour
faire campagne sans le dire c'était
quand même un concours de mauvaise foi
de la part d opposition qui se livrent
lorsqu'elles sont au pouvoir au même
genre d'exercice est par ailleurs
permettez moi quand même le coeur ça on
vient d'entendre des députés qui
appartiennent à des formations
d'opposition était au pouvoir vous
faites vous faites bien l'observer
précisément parce que les solutions
qu'elle propose ont jamais été élu c'est
bien heureux pour notre pays ce qu'il
s'agisse de monsieur mélenchon ou de
madame le pen deux politiciens ont gelé
leurs différents voilà c'était sur un
ring elles sont des politiciens oui des
politis heures parce qu'ils sont pas
d'accord l'un avec l'autre au sur leurs
positions politiques
et en fait ce qui est encore plus
évident c'est qu'il ya des centaines de
personnes autour qui se sont rassemblés
ça se passe dans le gymnase d'une école
pour assister à cet affrontement qui a
duré
gagnon ministre un jour rêvé un jour de
faire de la politique ou encore de 2,2
d'anciennes miss ministre alors il est
temps on mêle pas mis ces politiques et
donc pour l'instant pour l'instant de 20
stands rendez-vous dans tous les coups
sont passés pour régler le différend
entre le maire de bord bas au brésil et
l'ancien conseiller municipal de la
région pim pam poum à grands coups de
manivelle
c'est le maire qui a gagné malgré une
rafale de coups une nouvelle manière de
régler un différend alexandre benalla a
été placé en garde à vue ce matin c'est
une information tf l'ancien
collaborateur d'emmanuel maquereau a été
condamné le mois dernier pour violences
lors des manifestations du 1er mai 2018
l'objet de sa garde à vue d'aujourd'hui
est différent il est entendu à propos de
suspicion de blanchiment de trafic
d'influencé et de corruption
c'est l'écriture à twizy est
effectivement qui fait son apparition
sur cette pac qui rend hommage aux
conseillers de paris qui ont eu un
mandat plus de 25 ans et donc voilà la
mairie de paris a fait changer quelques
petits caractères sa valable pour deux
plaques c'est valable aussi pour
président présidente j'ai pas dans quel
ordre on le dit la grosse colère des
agriculteurs qui ont manifesté très tôt
ce matin devant le conseil d'état à
paris ils étaient plusieurs centaines et
ont rapidement été délogés par la police
balen vous le voyez ont été brûlées des
tracteurs ont déposé gros tas de fumier
ça a coûté 18 1609 euros à la
municipalité
dans un contexte de ville endettée à
hauteur de plus de 7 milliards
[Musique]